this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show it's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and i'm ken coleman host
of the ken coleman show
on the ramsey network joined by my
colleague dr john deloney host of the dr
john delony show
on the ramsey network you see a theme
yes
we are a part of ramsey solutions and
that means
we engage with you to help you get
practical solutions
to get ahead in the most important areas
of your life if it's about your life
we're here for you if it's about your
money we're here for you if it's about
your relationships if it's about
your work we are here for you you're not
where you want to be in your work you're
not where you want to be in your
relationships
you're not where you want to be your
money well that will be our focus
dr john delaney always good for
uh the opportunity to hang out together
we we have a lot of collaboration
turns out on our show a lot of people
calling about similar things
and when it comes to toxicity and not
being happy in their work
turns out there's some connections
between that and and and your
relationships
and not being happy with you yes
with that person you see in the mirror
yeah it's true it's uncomfortable
yeah when you take it to work with you
and you take it to your to your
marriages and you take it to
your parents you take it everywhere all
kinds of data out there on that so john
and i are gonna
we're gonna talk about that one of the
things that that might be fun let's
throw out some scenarios for people
because we we
on our shows we know where people are
hurting right give me two or three
scenarios people right now they're
hearing us and they go huh
i i need some help with that um man we
i'm getting flooded with calls from
moms and dads whose kids can't stay at
home anymore yeah they've been staring
at the screen for a calendar year yes
and now you're watching bipartisan
medical experts from across the country
at a university hospital saying enough
is enough is enough the downstream
affects these kids and so
how do you continue to parent your kid
when they're breaking down how do you
continue to
be married how do you continue to love
somebody who has different opinions and
thoughts about the stuff going on in the
world today so
relational issues and man
our lives were crazy and a mess before
the last before 2020 hit
they're already a mess and so this is
just exposing some cracks in our
relationships and our mental health and
our physical
all that stuff all together right yeah
what about you man well i'll tell you
what how about some people who want to
get a bigger shovel as dave ramsey has
said for years how about
how about you you're in the baby steps
you're working you're going ken i
i've always wanted to do this type of
work can i be
in the baby steps paying off debt
specifically and
change careers in order to make more
money the answer is yes
so we'll take on some of those strategic
moves how about that i love it lots of
people are just
they're just stuck yeah they're just
like man i've got a job i'm grateful for
it
yep but i want more yeah i want to see
meaning in my work
we'll take on some of things how about
some toxicity we take on how about we
got a toxic boss toxic
work culture just saying how about we
take that on together that's right
because you'll talk about how to handle
that emotionally and mentally and i'll
talk about hey what do we do what are
the moves to make so we always have a
lot of fun
i love it man i love it so let's open up
the phones here we go it's a free call
as you know triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go kirk is gonna
start us off in denver colorado kirk
how can we help hey dr john ken thanks
for taking my call you bet
so i have a question dr john about
dealing with feelings
of resentment and
basically i've been married for 10 years
we have two kids
and we have a wonderful marriage
relationship
and five years ago the business that i
started
moved from uh where we live about an
hour 45 minutes two hours
away and so i've been commuting for
those
five years about 800 000 miles a week
and 20 hours a week and um
initially it was a gradual thing we're
going to you know
move the business up there and then
we're going to you know grow it
and if it grows and if it happens well
everything went
according to plan and so now i'm in a
position where i've asked her
can we think about moving um last couple
years putting our heads the answer is
the resounding no and so as we
as a as i drive every day i'm building
resentment
and so i telling everything that's the
death of our relationship
and you know it's a comparison thing
where every time she adds something
to her plate whether that's you know
coaching or something extracurricular it
asks me to come home earlier or to ask
me to
do something on the weekends that i
don't
necessarily want to do because of the
commute because of the yeah the issues
so um you said two things that that
contradict each other
one is we've got this beautiful
relationship and two
i've got this this resentment that is
building every mile
down the road i get from my house every
time she says i need you to come home
early
which is a two-hour commute for you
there's something bigger going on here
than just this commute
what what is it
uh well i think it's that
she values i feel like she values other
things
the reasons for her staying which is her
job
the kids where we want them to grow up
her families here
over me and over my success and
my um grind that i'm doing and
so here here's the thing i don't think
that's necessarily that binary
but you have you are exactly right what
i'm gonna tell you is your your marriage
is on
um red alert right now okay yeah you
have made this into an either or
she is i'm not she's forced you into an
either or it's
not that but um in the nerd world we
call it fundamental attribution error
when you get into somebody else's head
and decide why they're making the
decisions they're making or why they're
not making the decisions they're making
and then you go to war with your own
explanations of why somebody else is
doing whatever it is they're doing
so here's the thing your marriage is in
trouble
am i going to mince words with you and
you again you can pipe in
you can't work two hours from your house
and commute every day and be a present
father and be a present husband
and at this point you're a paycheck and
a courier and that is
not that has no legs in a long-term
relationship
yeah here's what i would tell you kirk
you need to figure out what your
professional options are that might make
this better and to what john
said you are projecting some real
feelings that you're having
onto her and i think you got to sit down
and say here's what i'm feeling
and let her say well that's not true but
have you considered that
when you ask her to move and uproot to
be closer to your work
that you are asking her to do some
things that she's afraid of
right and so she has some very real
feelings on the other side of this
reality so one reality is this makes it
better for you
and your life easier but that same
suggestion makes her feel like oh i
don't want to do that instead of
hey we got to be a big boy and i'm going
to tell you uh you need to be the leader
here you need to be
the person who puts your feelings aside
for a moment and get some facts
hey kirk let me ask you this what's more
important to you at this point
if i told you you got to quit your job
today and find a job closer to home
or your marriage is gonna gonna end
my marriage of course there you go i
know you're gonna say that
so at some point you guys gotta get
across the table from one another
at this point i'm gonna tell you i think
you should get a neutral third party i
think you guys need to go see somebody
yeah
and you all stop communicating and then
that when you stop communicating it
falls into an either or when it falls
into either or then it's you versus me
and now we've gone to war
and no marriage can survive that your
kids don't deserve that she didn't
deserve that man you don't deserve that
you deserve to be connected and loved
resentment
i think is the cancer that will almost
kill any relationship if it's not
rooted out so get after this do what
john said
be a big man about this come up with
some other options all right
wow we're just getting started folks
don't move more of your calls about
life this is the ramsay show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping and a guaranteed
perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
providing you hope for a better future
and practical steps to make that future
a reality this
is the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
ramsey personality host of the ken
coleman show on the ramsey network
joined by my colleague
in studio today he's dr john deloney
host of the dr john deloney show
also on the ramsey network it occurs to
me that people must hear that and go wow
you spent a lot of time and money on
those show names
it is a lot of creative hours of people
in the room
and man i'm you're probably like me i
had so many
awesome kit like the laser show i mean i
had so many cool
laser show i would have liked that the
laser show with dr johnson
would that be feels like a vegas
actually see yeah like you would be on a
stage
with lasers i just had so many great
titles glad we didn't go with that did
not work out
all right folks we're here to take your
calls uh we're gonna take your calls on
money we'll take your calls
on your relationship mental health
emotional health we'll take your calls
on your work are you doing work you love
uh do you want to move up get that
bigger shovel you're dealing with some
toxicity at work
uh john and i can combine a lot of these
and we will
speaking of uh how many of you out there
right now
are in a position maybe because of the
pandemic that you
are needing a better job or
maybe you are listening right now and
you're saying hey i want to
make a transition so that i can move up
the ladder i want to
get that promotion if that is you or you
know somebody that
is in that boat i'm very excited john to
announce that uh ramsey solutions
and myself are combining again
for the second version of get hired we
did this event in june last year in the
middle of a pandemic
trying to help people who are displaced
here's where we sit there are 16
people uh unemployed for every open job
in the united states right now that's a
shift from
february of last year where there were
more jobs available than people who were
unemployed
so we are relaunching we're bringing it
back for a second uh
spectacular night april the 27th 8
eastern 7 central time i'll be live here
with a
a small and really fun vibrant crowd
here at
ramsey solutions headquarters and we'll
be beaming this all around the world
tickets start at twenty dollars so think
of if you've got three or
five people in your life that need this
that'd be a great gift hundred dollars
in your budget this month will give
people the edge
because the economy is warming back up
but it is still
very competitive so we're gonna go
through the first three stages of my
seven stages to meaningful work
get clear get qualified and get
connected all for the purpose
of getting hired it's gonna be a great
event again
get your tickets at daveramsey.com
ticket start at just 20 that's
daveramsey.com it's going to be a
really really fun night so tell
everybody you know that
needs wants to move up
move on in their professional work it's
gonna be a great night this may be
awkward but i probably need to get one
of those uh
tickets oh really yeah looking for a new
job i don't think i'm doing very well i
think it'd be great to
i think you're doing [ __ ] teach me
how to get connected i think you're
doing quite
well hey i have a question um
just a personal question on that last
show you you've handled this question
way more than i have
do you have a recommendation a
recommendation for for
folks for families on how far somebody
should commute to a job
you know well there's no set answer yeah
but it's a philosophical answer
so i'm not going to say it's 90 minutes
or two hours
whatever i think it is when it begins to
go from
okay we can do this we've adjusted to
this
to this is putting a strain on our
family gotcha
and that requires intentionality
intentionality and communication we got
to talk
so it might be okay for six months it
might have been okay for the last six
years
now the kids are older they're in more
sports so i'm gonna leave that open to
say
i think as a married couple if we're in
tune and we're paying attention to
everybody in the family
and for whoever the spouse is whichever
one of the family unit is doing the long
travel and so they're not there as much
versus and the other person who's having
to do more
everything so it's gone more and doing
more right whoever's gone more
okay who's how's that affecting
everybody because they're not there
they're leaving earlier getting home
later whatever
and then whoever's having to do more as
a result of the one who's gone more
if it begins to now this is a strain we
need to adjust
you gotta adjust yeah that's my formula
how does that fit with the uh mental and
emotional health i i've
i think i think most people don't um do
the hard work
of sitting down with somebody they care
about and express how they feel about
something
um i think it we avoid hard
conversations for so long
that you just keep getting in the car
and driving and i think most of us
don't actually know what it is that
frustrates us what it is that's driving
us what feelings we're actually having
about stuff
and so i get home and i'm frustrated at
my kids or i'm frustrated after this or
actually i'm frustrated that i miss
folks and i've been driving for 45 years
you make a very good point and i want to
add to my answer because you just
addressed something it's not just the
strain on everybody else but if your
heart's hurting too much that's it
right that's what you just described
because eventually that's going to come
out the way you describe
you're angry at the world and yourself
and eventually i think you're angry at
yourself
my heart's hurting yeah i'm doing this
to me you know i got to that point i'll
tell you early on when i did the first
version of the ken coleman show back in
atlanta i was uh
on a local radio station monday through
friday and i was doing the 5 to 7 p.m
slot while the kids were three
i had three kids under three well you
know this yeah it was 45 minutes away
i got home at 7 55 maybe 8 o'clock i
missed it all
they're already upstairs stacy was
getting them out of the bath
someone was asleep and i got to tell you
after six months of that my heart was
hurting those are the magic moments you
don't get those back yeah so i went to
the station general andre i said would
you be open to me moving from
five to seven to three to five and
thankfully they were
that's cool and you want to talk about a
game changer yeah your marriage works
better
your connection with your kids works
better and then you get to settle into
that that's a real life example yeah
mine i've always worked very close
that's just always been a thing i want i
want to
be one or two miles from home and i
agree now i've got more of a commute and
do your thing we're just having to
adjust right
and some families are fine we have some
good friends uh that live in our
neighborhood here
and he works in atlanta and every sunday
night
he drives atlanta comes back uh on
thursday
gets home before the kids are home uh so
late late thursday afternoon
it's working right now i talked to him
last year how's your heart he goes we're
good man we're good so
if you know some people can do it right
but when your heart hurts where there's
a strain that's when you know we got to
make a change that's right love it
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
max is joining us in the big apple new
york city
new york max how can we help hey guys
how are you today
well we're having a blast how can we
help you
all right um so i recently just got
married uh
last year my wife and i were 27 years
old we both worked
um and we've been renting in manhattan
for about five years now and
i'm sure as you guys know we pay you
know you pay an arm and a leg for rent
in manhattan so uh you know we started
talking about
purchasing a home and we make pretty
decent money together we have a nice
chunk of savings combined and we're just
kind of lost as far as
how much house can we afford what's your
income
tell me your take home best as you can
tell me
our take-home uh it's tough because
everything gets taken out automatically
we do like 210
combined gross okay 210 gross
all right and how much do you have in
savings
uh between the both of us it's about 830
000.
whoa now when you say between the both
of us
uh oh do we have separate accounts here
she holds the ball
well you guys got a a pronoun problem
here y'all are married so that's y'alls
savings
yeah you can't you can't separate that
brother yeah it needs to be joint
accounts you said how much 8 30
about about 8 30. okay so after the
market today gotcha 830 000 okay and
what are you looking at from a house
standpoint what have you guys
you guys have been out looking you
either been on websites or you've gone
out maybe and
seen a few homes what are you thinking
what do you think we're looking
anywhere from i would say a million to
one
two but my wife is under you know the
the notion that you know she doesn't
want to start her home she wants to just
be in the big house and
call it a day and i'm looking more for
let's cut it back by a couple hundred
thousand
let's grow our family and start and you
know we could always
move up if things go well for us all
right well we gotta handle this real
quick
i'm gonna let john address that real
quick the communication piece here's
what we teach at ramsey solutions okay
that you uh you need to the amount of
house you can afford and should afford
is 25 of your take-home pay but now
you've got 830 000
in the bank do you have any debt yes or
no
no okay great then there you go you got
a huge down payment you guys
you guys can get house but i would still
be conservative 25
of your take home pay john and sit down
and don't let this deal
be a deal breaker between we want the
big fancy house in the in the starter
house
y'all sit down and have an honest
conversation with one another about what
you're trying to do i'd much rather see
a young couple like y'all be out of debt
buy a house you can afford and have no
payments you got a
big down payment you can dump on there
and then grow your family over time
move up in house as the market allows
yeah
get on the same page you guys are in
great shape congratulations
big down payment be conservative then
grow all right don't move
more of your calls coming up this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back this is the ramsey show
coming to you from ramsay solutions
worldwide headquarters in nashville
thrilled to have you with us dr john
deloney
my colleague joins me ken coleman we are
ramsey personalities we host uh
shows uh entitled uh the same as our
name what is the word eponymous
uh what's the word what it's it means
the same is the name the same
you know what i'm talking about that's a
very fancy word i'll look it up later i
it's like
a word you just said but i can't
pronounce it i'm not sure
yeah kelly's a word nerd uh what is that
word can you look that up do you know
what i'm talking about
it's uh eponymous how eponymous
hippopotamus hippopotamus hey folks
we're doing it live here
every once in a while you throw a word
out and you're like i think i said that
right but i'm not sure and i care enough
to address it but uh nonetheless what i
was meant to say is he's the host of the
john dr john delony show
that would have been easier it would
have been easy and i'm the host of the
ken coleman show on the ramsay network
and so
uh john talks about your mental and
emotional health as well as
relationships i talk about doing work
that matters deeply to you working on
purpose
which by the way coincides with living
on purpose so
we also talk money as well because this
is ramsay solutions and the ramsey show
so
we're gonna talk about your life how can
we help you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to san diego california next where
jacinta
joins us how can we help hey dr john
ken thank you for taking my call you bet
uh me and my husband we are on baby step
two we are 69k
in debt we have four kids under eight we
are a navy family
my husband's a sailor and i myself am
looking to
just make my shovel bigger i
i have my bachelor's degree um i did
that while we were stationed in virginia
for a while
and raised the babies got my bachelor's
but now i'm looking to just kind of
advance a little bit and apply it to the
accelerated nursing program
i it should take me about three years i
have some core nursing
courses to take and then the 24 months
of the nursing program
to do okay so what's your question
um my question is if i should even do it
we have four kids uh my husband's in the
navy he deploys next year most likely
and nursing school is just a ton of work
i
you know i know what it takes my friends
went through it and i'm
nervous about it but i i know i could do
it um
we do have help of the family back home
here in california
and i'm wanting to use a gi bill um like
i said we're 69k
and get so and part of that is a student
loan which i will never ever do again
i'm not even thinking about that so um
thinking the gi bill might help us a ton
with that
of course and then that go ahead well
here's the deal
do you want to do this because when you
don't want to when somebody calls up and
asks you this question
i i can give you thoughts but when
someone says
should i do it that means you've already
got a thought
you've already got your answer you might
have two answers you might have a head
answer
and you might have a heart answer what
do you have one answer do you have a
head answer and a hard answer and what
is the answer what is your answer
well to be honest i want to just make my
shovel bigger because being a
stay-at-home mom
i work at target right now i make 15 an
hour i'm getting minimal hours maybe 20
25
and i want to do better for myself you
know i've been a mom
my kids are all under eight i've been
maybe why if i want to kind of put
myself first uh my
head goal is to be director of nursing
and i know that's going to take some
time
okay hold on so here's the deal you want
to be
director of nursing this isn't just a
job for you gave me the just a job i
want to make more money i want a bigger
shovel
i want to do this this and this for my
family that was the answer you just gave
me
but i want to know the hard answer when
you choose nursing
i think you chose it for a specific
reason
and when you say things like i want to
be a director of nursing i want to lead
other nurses is essentially what you're
saying
there's a why behind that tell me the
why
um to make more money okay so it is just
a job
it is just a job this isn't work that
you're deeply passionate about you don't
have a deep desire
to be a nurse it's not something you've
always wondered about yes or no
yeah but i've never really got to
explore what i'm passionate about i mean
i've worked a little part-time jobs
and i don't really know i'm more of a
mom and that's kind of been my main
passion
i think you do know let's take nursing
out for a second let's take all the
things you've just
really done a great job of laying out
all the things you got to do and why you
would do it
and there's a good economic case that
you've made but here's what i want to
know
i want you to suspend your brain just
for a few seconds
if you knew you could not fail you
didn't have to worry about child care
kids it was just this fun work adventure
everybody was fine in the family
everybody was taking care of it you
could go do this work
and you didn't have to commit to it for
the rest of your life but it was going
to make you more money and you were
going to be successful at it
what would you try
i know i want to do something in the
medical field but
you're right nursing i don't know if i
can do
the hands-on with the patients i've been
a cna in that kind of
so here's the deal i'm going to push you
a little bit so i'm going to push you
because you're really doing great your
heart's starting to reveal the answer
what would you do in the medical field
forget about title
forget about how possible it is what
would you do big fun adventure ken and
john get to put me on what would you do
in the medical field hands on go say it
i would be director of nursing i would
do it i want to do that
okay so should you want a leadership
role
i want a leadership role yeah i want to
do the hiring part i want to do the
office
all right hr i want to work in a
hospital i want to work with
you know people that help but in order
to get them to help you have to hire
them you have to direct them in the
right space and lead them and i want to
be
okay i'm not part of the end of that so
here's the deal so here's the deal
we got all the way around came back to
it and you just blurted it out i want to
be in the medical field
i want to be hands-on but you're more
not the medicine but you're about the
people
right yeah great so here's the deal yeah
you got to become a nurse in order to
eventually hire and lead nurses
so the answer is yes but here's what i
don't want you to feel the pressure to
do
you don't have to do it right this
second right maybe
maybe the question with you and your
husband tonight over dinner or a date on
the weekend john i want you to jump into
this is
when is the right time to do this with
the kiddos you do have the child care
feels like you've gone through a lot of
these things you do have the gi bill
which is huge for you
and you can start to make progress now
but i would just make absolutely sure
when is the right time to do this but my
answer is
your answer right which is yes you
should do this
don't doubt it the question is when and
how
jacinta as your husband is getting
deployment orders
and you know he's going to be going
overseas next year
how much are you feeling in your heart
that he's doing this big huge thing
and you feel like i'm just a mom and
there's 69 thousand dollars that i could
be helping on he's going to do this
dr john you're good that's exactly how
i've been telling you so listen
your husband's a stud you know this
right
yeah he's listening right now on his way
home he's a stud on behalf of your
family
on behalf of his fellow soldiers and
behalf of my kids who he's never met
and ken's kids who he will never meet
and
you're a stud yes you are
taking care of four humans under the age
of eight
i would call you a superhero that's a
weather event
right every day yeah and so do you guys
have 69 grand
between the two of you yup do you have
it yeah you do
do you have to solve all that like ken
said right now no
there is an industry that exists to make
moms of all types
feel less than oh you want to be a
full-time mom you should be working oh
you're working you should be at home
or oh you only have two kids you should
have 11. you had 11 kids what kind of
selfish person are you
you can't win so get out of that game
one other thing
get rid of the guilt there's some guilt
you're holding i'll let john take care
of this but she's got guilt on her like
a giant blanket
for her debt is this is this debt yours
did you bring the student loan debt into
the
your marriage yes i did and um another
one is his type r he has a sports car
that i'm like
sell your car but then i feel like maybe
he deserves it
but then it would help us um that's our
lowest oh he's listening right now you
just dropped uh
that was very well played well played
yes you should sell the car charger sell
the car
sell the car yeah but listen listen
he married you because he loves you
you're a great mom
you're a great um soldier's wife we need
you as much as we need him
put the guilt down y'all come up with a
plan together to pay this debt off
over time i don't think four kids and a
deployment is a great time to go back to
grad school does it make
that's gonna be a wild ride but you
can't do it but it's gonna be busy
hang on jacinta kelly let's give them a
free trial to ramsey plus you two need
to get
together get into ramsey plus and get
get together on the process of financial
peace
and get that baby step working work
those baby steps and get out of debt
and get on the same page with your
vision before you know it that 69
000 is gone and you guys are doing what
you
want to do sell the car sell the car
ramsey show continues in just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
deloney as we take you through this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five
two two five what do you need some help
with you need to get something off your
chest come on
uh the doctor is in and then uh i've got
an opinion or two as well
so it's a nice combo we'll talk about
money we'll talk about emotions we'll
talk about work
how about all three of those money work
mental
emotional health parenting schooling
parenting
the advice is worth exactly what you pay
for it which is awesome
how about this one i get this one a lot
john have had in the last week on the
ken coleman show
had two couples call in together because
i've been telling them hey
because i get a lot of spouses will call
in saying hey my spouse is not happy
yeah they're miserable at their work
they don't like it they feel down
they've been they've been out of the
workforce for a certain amount of time
they're depressed blah blah blah
you know and they're trying to help so
we'll get them on
yeah because on the youtube i'll go i'll
tell you what play this back i'm going
to talk to them what's their name
i'll look at the camera all right larry
listen to me yeah you know what i mean
love it and so we'll do that today
you know if you need help connecting
with a spouse well i love it how do you
encourage the spouse to do
give them that nudge of confidence how
do you help them but not
push them that's right that's a tricky
thing too so we'll take it all
well and if you've got a someone who
loves and cares about you
and you've given them permission to
speak into your life can this happen
to me this week i was walking through
our bedroom and my wife stopped me and
she said
you will stop talking to my husband like
you've been talking to in the last two
weeks
i slipped into just some negative
self-talk running my mouth about myself
and
she said stop stop i love that guy
and you're gonna quit talking to him
like yeah boy it was just a good call
yeah man i've been right and i wouldn't
have heard it i would have just thought
my thoughts were right because we always
think our thoughts and our own emotions
and feelings are right and
i got to snap out a little bit and yeah
so yeah i love it when somebody calls
and says i love
somebody who i'm sharing a house with
and they're not good i don't know what
to say
i don't want to help them right that's a
tricky situation that's right i love it
yeah so we'll take those calls as well
all right caroline joins us in
greenville
north carolina caroline how can we help
hi dr john and ken really appreciate you
taking my call
sure um so i'm calling
because i'm feeling a little bit burned
out and i need some advice
um basically in a nutshell i'm
i'm 52 my husband's 55 we have two girls
one is about to finish college and the
other one
is going to college in about a year
um we have in
during the pandemic we've managed to pay
off our house
wow i know i know and um
i'm a respiratory therapist so i travel
um
so that's part of my thing that i want
to talk to you about
um i try to stay close to home i go to
south carolina i go to
a middle part of the state and work in
the hospitals there i also last year
worked up
in dc for about three months and in
between i would come
home for a few days and then get right
back out to it
we were so focused for two years trying
to pay down
our home and then the rental property
and the goal was maybe to pay off the
other rental property and then
we looked at everything and i just said
why don't we just
sell these two properties and then our
house is paid for and then we can just
breathe and we we were very fortunate we
used one of your elps and within two
weeks both of our properties were sold
within uh within uh um about two months
everything was completely paid off wow
you are dead
free i mean 100
yeah that happened in october and um
you know we've worked really hard just
paying that down so basically we paid 80
000 down we were working on the next 80
000
and uh we you know so basically in two
years we paid about 160 000.
and that allowed us to by selling those
two properties the house is completely
what's causing you to feel like you may
be
burning out what's going on we have we
have really
you know i have to tell you your budget
app
i just can't say enough about it i was
pretty organized with everything we
had everything down on paper but it was
the day-to-day stuff like the food the
groceries the good for you you know
miscellaneous stuff and that has
really helped us uh so anyway that
really just kind of you know ramped it
up
so now everything on paper looks good
we seem to be good but caroline you
started off the call
caroline listen to me i'm trying to get
you and i feel like you might be dodging
this a little bit why do you
feel like you might okay i'll tell you
what it is
i'll tell you what it is so i love being
home
uh but i also love the money that i'm
making
um and my family loves it too yeah sure
um
so i'll just tell you in a nutshell i
know what it is
can i guess can i guess what it is
caroline i'm trying to help you because
we got
we got to get to this i think your
heart's hurting really bad all this
travel you love the job you love the
work i'm tired
well you're emotionally tired john i
think her heart is just spent
and can i put something else on top of
you you
are about to lose your last kid yeah
empty nester yep yeah
you just cleared this major hurdle and
this is
your other daughter's about to be gone
from college and you're
you're not all this transition is just
whirling and turning in your soul and
your home and your husband's
heart and soul everywhere i have a
question caroline i'll tell you
can i tell you something real quick
really fast
okay so i work three months um
doing a contract i can take off time
and i just haven't do it and carolina
you're talking about their trip
in july caroline listen to me caroline
caroline listen to me
i got a question for you can you afford
to quit this job right now in this
season of life
it's a yes or no answer yes yes we have
almost
400 000. caroline caroline quit
you have a limited amount of time with
your last baby
before she goes off to college john
nailed it
and that's what your heart is telling
you to do your brain's going
well you got a really good job you make
really good money and we got lots of
toys and we
actually can buy more toys we get a lot
to do a lot of things now we've been
sacrificed for so long i don't know what
to do i don't know what to do i don't
know what to do let me tell you what you
need to do you need to listen to your
heart
and caroline your heart's telling you to
quit take some time
off the break yes listen once baby flies
once the last baby flies out of the nest
then you can think about re-entering and
doing something that's close to home but
you can do something even bigger than
that your husband can say yeah it's just
you and me babe
now what yeah that's right we're a
little over halfway done here because
y'all are both gonna live to be 110
yep we're a little over halfway what do
we want this to look like what kind of
work we want to do do you want to go
back to traveling
but you guys have gazelle sprinted and
if that gazelle keeps sprinting and
sprinting the lions don't catch him he
just dies of a heart attack
mm-hmm yeah exactly so
take a breath and that's what i'm seeing
in my patients my population
and that's what i was kind of like oh my
gosh i have got to slow down a little
bit well you called because you were
looking for permission
john she was looking for permission i've
had this call granted a thousand times
on my show and i'm just gonna tell you
granted
permission granted your husband may miss
the the paycheck
he's gonna love getting his girlfriend
back
he might he might be a little irritated
when she tells you to pick up his socks
but that's good for him that's fantastic
because she's been in and out and this
is going to not just
it's not this really i'm not so much
worried about her being physically tired
john
i'm worried about the emotional because
there's a lot of emotional
capital calories spent uh trying to get
out of debt
and sacrifice and especially in a job
that's all about secondary traumatic
stress where you are
living in the pain of other people for a
profession right absolutely
that wears you out where's your you can
take some time to get well go for walks
be with your daughter absorb that last
time help your
other daughter transition from college
you know what i think she needs to do
caroline i think you need to set some
fun new things i think you need to
announce your resignation to at least
your family tonight
and then do it the right way which i
know you will you'll be classy and leave
well but john i think she needs a
standing
uh nail appointment or standing
something they spot with the glass
she's going to create something at her
breakfast with my daughter love it and
she's going to tell her i know you don't
want to go i'm your mom you have to
it's the last semester before you go we
are hanging out every monday that's just
gonna be what that is uh and it's gonna
be great
oh i love that caroline you're rock star
congrats to you and your husband you are
debt-free so cool so now you can live
and give like no one else awesome stuff
hey i want to thank our producer james
childs our associate producer kelly
daniel
and my colleague dr john deloney but
most of all we want to thank you america
this
is your show this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
coming to you live from the headquarters
of ramsey solutions
and broadcasting from the dollar car
rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
life
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john dolone
we are taking you through this hour as
we answer
one caller at a time giving hope
and practical steps to get where you
want to be whether it is in your
money it is in your work your pursuit of
purpose
in your relationships and your emotional
mental health we are here for
you and we have a blast doing it
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number it's toll free
jump in triple eight eight two five five
two two five john
as i was saying right before we came on
the only thing missing right now on this
giant desk is a plate of barbecue
barbecue all manner of meats and sides
i think that's what this was missing but
other than that we're ready to go we
have all the ingredients
just barbecue donuts would be good too
you like donuts they're not good for you
but i love them yeah i love them all
right all right we'll see we can yeah
barbecue would be excellent
yeah we'll talk to the production we're
looking at you get a platter
production barbecue and then a side of
doughnuts for doctor
not eating donuts man i fall asleep
right in the middle of the show
boom forehead down that's why i know
you're getting old
when food you're stuck yeah i'm out yeah
you know you're old when carbs threaten
your consciousness
that's it's like oh boy and you're it's
a multi-day event
yes i i finished a no sugar challenge
ken
yeah uh a couple days ago i partnered
with it with a with a navy seal
i was having to text him every day not a
good idea not a good idea and
people shouldn't partner with if i
missed a day the punishment was going to
be brutal so i i made it
my life philosophy is don't ever fall
off a wagon but occasionally you got to
park the wagon and
step off of it how soon after the
challenge was over did you get sure i
made myself go two days
so two extra days and then i went for it
and here's the thing what was the moment
what was the thing you cheated with
i did a speech for a group here and they
gave me like a
fish bowl sized bowl of gummy candy and
marshmallow products of all sorts
it's it's my it's my okay sweet spot as
you would say yeah not not where i would
have gone with it but that was you when
in rome they gave you a bowl they gave
you a bowl of
of and as i was sort of eating it yeah i
thought this isn't just going to cost me
today
and tonight it's going to be a multi-day
affair because i'm old
it is true i'm old it is true well
you're not going to take care of your
body no doughnuts just
barbecue would be awesome yes all right
well i'm sufficiently hungry
let's go help some people let's go to
ben who joins us in pittsburgh
pennsylvania ben how can we help all
right gentlemen thank you
so much for taking my call you bet well
my question is this uh i'm
27 years old i live at home still i'm
on baby step two uh the only debt that i
have is my college loans
how much is that um it's about thirty
five thousand dollars um
it's kind of a sticky situation uh i was
at another university before i
transferred to the university that i
graduated with
um and after graduating from there i
received a letter from the federal trade
commission
that there was a lawsuit for fraud so
it's kind of being investigated right
now
um but essentially enough that's not
actually my my main reason for calling
uh my my main reason for calling is i've
always been close with my family
um i have six siblings and my my parents
are very much about helping their kids
and getting them started on their feet
right
and i thank them so much for that
however lately
i've been butting heads with my father
in the sense of
um moving out and getting on my own i've
brought up the idea of renting multiple
times to him
and him being a renter himself and has
also had
tenants in houses that he does own he
strongly
persists that i don't do that and insist
that i stay home and save for a house
i'm kind of looking on some guidance to
see if that's good advice because
i'm not getting any younger you know my
sister is getting married she's moving
out this year my other brother just
bought a house
he's going to be moving out within the
end of the year and i'm kind of stuck
if if i should move out and rent and and
start my life or if i should
ben what do you do what do you do for a
living brother uh i work in i.t for a
university here
close to pittsburgh what do you make a
year uh right now making fifty one
thousand dollars a year yeah move out
tomorrow yeah
okay you're i'm gonna say this as nicely
as i can because i i trust you that your
dad's a good man and
and i love that you are connected as you
are to your family your 27 year old man
making 51 000
a year your dad didn't get a vote and if
you still owe 35 000
student loans you're not in a position
to buy a house and you need to get your
debt paid off
and then get a down payment saved up and
get an emergency fund saved up
which you can go buy a cheap one-bedroom
apartment
start having a life start
differentiating yourself from your
family doesn't mean you don't love them
doesn't mean you're not connected to
them but that means that they're not
making decisions for you because you're
27 year old man
and then you're going to be in a
position to buy a house
down the road you're not that's not you
don't you're not financially ready for
that
right and that's the point that i
brought up to him as a i'm like you know
i could
get married next year i did he
you know like that that's not an easy
thing to do when you have let me ask ben
a question
ben i'm going to ask you a question so
that you can answer and my colleague can
actually dive into this
okay i love this tina's both up then t
and you're both up
what's your what's your stomach for
telling dad what john
already told you you already started
coming up with more things feels like
you're just keeping this thing alive
and i want to know stomach uh meaning
you've got the guts to look at dad and
say it exactly the way that john
said it is it a one is it a five is it a
ten where is it on a scale of one to ten
one being i'm terrified to do it it
makes me sick to think about it ten
i'm ready to go i just needed permission
um
i would probably say it's about a five
or six i could tell them but you know
i mean we've been so close to the family
so you look for that approval
wait a second wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait i got one more question john
do you really think that he's gonna
disown you
no of course he's not but you're acting
like it
i acknowledge john he might be a little
upset and think that i think his son is
not being wise
are you are you the oldest i'm the
oldest boy yes that was his first son
so it is always a shock to the system
the first time a grown child
tells their parents i'm grateful for
your advice i'm going east
yeah or i'm going west and that always
sends a shock away through the family
system
it will take some getting used to
because they're not used to this they've
got six kids the oldest
the oldest of which is almost 30 and
they're you're still living at home as
though you were 16.
here's the thing asking your dad the
same advice overnight you know what no
he's going to say
so going back to that going back to that
it's great there needs to be a
transition
from where your parents give you their
thoughts on things
but not the answers on things and this
is your moment
let me tell you something let me say
this hey ben
i'm going to give enough time for my
colleague to clean this up if i mess
this up but let me tell you what i think
you're going to be right listen ben the
very man
that you are so worried about his
approval
if you don't do this your desire for
approval and love and connection is
going to turn into deep resentment
i'm telling you am i right john and
resentment is the
it's a killer it's it's the kill
relationship that's right so if you
don't do what john said you're going to
end up resenting your dad because here's
the deal
your head heading hard or clear on what
you need to do you're just worried that
dad's gonna be upset with me so take him
out to take him out to a big boy lunch
you pay oh yeah let him know hey dad i'm
really grateful
but i've decided to move out i'm gonna
start my adventure on my own i'm almost
30 and it's time i'm so grateful for
your help up until now
but it's time for me to move on yep this
is the ramsey show we'll be right back
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help
get you there plus they offer
unbelievable financial benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
so
the ramsey show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney and
we are thrilled to have you with us
taking your calls about life whether
it's
money whether it is hey i'm not happy in
my work i want to get a bigger shovel i
want to do more
i want to work on purpose or hey i've
got some
some mental emotional stuff i got some
relationship stuff get some kids stuff
get some spouse stuff whatever it is
john and i are here to help triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five
five two two five we consider what we do
work that matters and
to that note uh before we get back to
the phones i want to let you know that
ramsay solutions
we're all about transforming lives and
we want
to get more people to help us do this
imagine
being a part of disrupting the toxic
culture whether the money culture the
work culture the relationship culture
you can be a part of it we want to
disrupt the toxicity in this world with
hope and practical
solutions that's why ramsey solutions we
have a thousand people
working together to create digital
products and services to help people
transform their lives
and if you would like to join us on that
crusade we are on the hunt for many
software engineers with expertise in
ruby on rails java
c-sharp and front-end technologies or if
you're a ux
designer seo and content marketing
specialist we'd love to talk with you
find out about all of the available jobs
by texting
the phrase work that matters
no spaces there text the phrase work
that matters to three three seven eight
nine that's three three seven eight nine
text work that matters to three three
seven eight nine to find out about all
of our open opportunities
all right to the phones we go triple
eight eight two five five two two five
atlanta georgia is where adam joins us
adam how can we help
hey guys what's going on
got a question for john fellow texan
here but obviously we're down in atlanta
hey we got to spread the love everywhere
right i'm in nashville so
what's what's up hey man so second
marriage
been married 10 years got two kids with
my first wife
16 and 14 and a 16 year old has been
living with us for two years now
my wife and i are expecting any day now
and so my 16 year old
is you know we're in we're in family
therapy
and he is extremely jealous
and depressed and and wants to
wants to move out and and move home with
mom you know with the
with the uh introduction of the baby
coming home
so we need some tools that you know can
help us cope
with this and you know some things that
obviously we can
you know give some tools to him as well
but
as of right now i mean he's he's really
tuning everybody out here
yeah so so the basically adam the baby's
a proxy
what's what's what's beneath that how
long has he been struggling
now he's been struggling since he moved
with us two years ago
what precipitated that move why do you
have to move in with y'all
um expelled from school okay uh
you know alcohol and alcohol and drugs
at you know
11 12 13 years old that you know nobody
nobody knew about and and when it
happened he was expelled that
you know so he's 16. he's 16
and does that mean y'all got your
divorce was when he was about six
five uh yeah about three
about three yeah divorced in 2007.
he was about three his brother was just
over one years old okay
so when he was three he lived with mom
and went back and forth and back and
forth
back and forth multiple times a year
from texas to michigan
okay so baby's just the latest
man he's been living with who am i and
chaotic systems
since he has any recollection in fact
before he's got recollection his body
has stored this stuff
all over the place this level of trauma
and this level of
dysfunction and so what does your
therapist say when y'all go to family
counseling
what what where what are they
recommending
well you know we're kind of pressing
your therapist now
we'll meet without him and then we meet
with him or he'll meet by himself
and you know we just haven't seen a lot
of progress because he
you know he just repeatedly says that
he's depressed but he never
he never has any clarity to that
yeah 16 year olds man it's asking a lot
of a 16 year old to be
clear to be able to unpack emotions
be able to unpack feelings to be able to
unpack hormones to be able to unpack
this what did i do to cause this this co
this
chaos that's been present in my life the
last 5 10
15 years that's a tall order and so
the the impetus falls on the parents in
these moments
to do the connecting towards the kid do
they have to be accountable for their
actions absolutely do they have to
have good behavior absolutely all they
need those boundaries those are
important
but to sit there and say hey you're
telling me you're depressed
unpack that for me that's that's hard
for somebody that hasn't been given
those tools over the years
um what is your relationship with him
like one on one y'all are out
walking somewhere y'all going shopping
together you're out fishing together
whatever that looks like
what's your relationship with him like
typically one on one it's good
um you know we we joke around a lot
you know we go to the gym and we you
know we train together
uh you know we do stuff here at the
house we do our yard work together
stuff like that our relationship is
is good but it seems like his bond is
shifting more towards mom
here in the past you know six seven
eight nine months it's just increasing
and so it's almost like he he puts on a
persona where everything is fine you
know he's always smiling and
you know like in good spirits and
excited when he gets home from school
but
you know when he talks to anybody else
you know i'm depressed
and you know things of that nature but
and sometimes
every every teenager is different so i'm
not going to be able to give you hey you
need to go do this this
and this but i will tell you there are
some situations where
teenagers are will are looking for ways
to connect
and if him saying hey i'm depressed
hey i i i'm not doing well is that's
what it takes to get the people who love
him in his life to stop and look him in
the eye and say hey how are we doing
then they'll do that or he's
actually struggling and does not have
the words to put into context how much
he's hurting
my guess is it's been going on a long
long time and he's continuing to look
for different behaviors and so
you're right to press your family
therapist you're in the right place i
would be telling you to go do this
to go find a professional and if you're
not getting some concrete things that
can help heal that relationship
now or to help you connect with him
now then get another therapist find
somebody's gonna give you some practical
tips to help heal this relationship
um and man if if moms
if mom's a safe place for him to go i
don't have a problem with him going back
to moms if that's where he needs to be
to be successful right now
ken you've got two teenage boys
what's it like trying to get them to
connect their
their their words with their what's
going on in their heart and heads uh
it would be like trying to sandpaper a
bobcat's butt
telephone booth i don't even know
exactly right that's hard enough it's
tough
it's it's to the point where you they're
only going to tell you what they want to
tell you
um and you know more about this you know
we're learning too that you know
at that age they can't even articulate
that's
is if we think they can because they're
15 or they're 16 and they've got all
kinds of words
but then when they have to actually
confront their emotions and then there's
this
you know what are they going to tell mom
and dad versus what they'll tell friends
um and i can tell you from our journey
that
we can never truly predict although we
have learned that there are
circumstances
and and moods and ways that we can get
them to a point where they will open up
to us they're still deciding it's not
like we sit and go tell us
and there's no great technique you know
that
but it's hard and i think what i was
going to ask you in this situation is i
feel for this
this this man um how do the parents stay
healthy and we're going to break but
maybe something to talk about is at some
point how the parents stay healthy when
their kid's not healthy
that's tough you've got to make that
priority numero you have to you got to
be okay
with them not being okay that's right
and that doesn't feel very parental
right when we come back let's talk about
some of these words that kids throw
around
all right we'll tee it up hit us
differently than it may let's do maybe
experience yeah let's do that all right
don't move
parents pay attention maybe get that
teenager to listen in with you right now
i don't know we'll see what's going to
happen this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined this hour by my colleague
dr john deloney
and uh as we went into our last break we
were talking to a dad
a mixed family uh situation going on uh
different different uh biological
parents and for second marriage all this
kind of stuff and
he's just really uh he's really hurting
for his 16 year old
and uh who's telling others yeah that
he's that he's got some depression going
on
but seems like their relationship is he
recounted to you pretty good
he feels like things are good but he's
hearing this over here it's confusing
and then
i can just tell you uh as a non-clinical
guy here as a dad of three
teens um boy i tell you what you just
hurt when you feel like your kids are
hurting
and so as we went to break john i said
to you i said you know i think it's so
hard for parents
to learn how to be healthy when their
kids aren't healthy or another way of
saying it is
how does a parent be okay when your kids
aren't okay and i'm not saying you're
okay that things are rough in their life
of course you're not but it's like how
do you keep things in perspective and
john
i'm asking that yeah i'm asking that too
because you know it just happens
teenage being a teenager in 2021 has got
to be brutal
i gotta believe it's way worse than us
what we had yeah
so one of the things that i would tell
all parents is what you just said
your kids can't be okay if your marriage
isn't okay
right and we often get that mixed around
and so couples will break up into
into t like workforce mode right to make
sure the kids are doing these things and
what what gets sacrificed on that altar
of
our kids are busy and they're doing
things and everything's exciting and
they're happy
is our marriage and you gotta invert
that you
and the person you're married to you've
gotta be okay right
and then and only then can your kids
anchor into that
that solid foundation but i think as as
the last caller was
was was speaking i was thinking man we
we've got this passing in the night of
we're all using the word depression
it means something different to a
clinical person it means something
different to a dad
who's got some guilt about a divorce
he's got some guilt about a frustrated
kid 14 and 16 year old and now we got a
one
a new a newborn baby from a new marriage
is coming all this stuff has happened at
the same time
and then you get a kid that man seems
like things are great when we're around
each other
but then you go tell other people i'm
depressed right so
the first the most important thing that
um that family's doing that is right is
they're sitting with a with a family
counselor
how can we work through this with a
professional we got now we're gonna have
a blended family
and one of the one of the things i
remember one of my
counseling professors dr aretha marble
one of the most brilliant women i've
ever
had the opportunity to to know said when
when you have a new kid coming into a
situation
always rally the older kids with the
words
your your brother your kid right
give them some ownership and some
participation in this
not so much there's jealousy not so much
that there's a burden here
with that last dad was immediately
saying hey my kid's frustrated because
he's jealous man it's so much deeper
than that right
these kids these teenagers are desperate
to heal that chaos and that that
frustration and that burning
why did my parents get divorced the
first time why do i have to choose
between these two parents
now you're bringing another kid in what
are you doing it's 20 20 right oh and
i'm just going to stare at a screen all
day too right
it's all of that so parents you got to
stop asking your kids to
to speak like adults sometimes they
don't have the language to articulate
their emotions and all of their feelings
and all of
this and that's they can communicate
with
connection they can communicate with can
we just go play ball can we just throw
i'm not going to ask you more questions
i'm not going to give you more advice
can we just go ahead can we have
breakfast together i'm going to make you
a breakfast with me you can sit in
silence good will hunting style we can
ride this out in silence but we're gonna
do this
and i'm just gonna tell you i love you
right if your kid is experiencing
hopelessness
if your kid is experiencing helplessness
if they used to be really good and find
things really exciting suddenly they
just fall off the map
that's when you know hey we're in some
we're struggling here yeah
dig into those relationships with those
kids right
and if you do all of a sudden if you
have a 16 or 14 year old and all of a
sudden you find out
hey we're having another one yeah man
get way ahead of that right get way
ahead of that
if your kid tells you i want to go live
with mom and mom's safe
sitting all right mom and if yeah it's
not your battle to lose man you want
your kid to be safe and be okay so
there's a lot of mess there man but at
the end of the day make sure your
marriage is whole make sure you're good
and don't give up on these kids yeah
good stuff there all right let's go to
new york city new york where alexandra
joins us alexander how can we help
hi i wanted to first thank you both for
uh taking my call and speaking to me
today i really
really love the show and love all you
guys thank you
and dr john congrats on your recent show
i've been enjoying that as well
thank you so much i only got about three
listeners and so you're one of them so i
appreciate you
sure you have way more than that
anyway so what's up my question
yeah my question for you both is um
how can i feel more secure about money
i'm 32 years old
i was always a spender um coming out of
college as luckily
able to not have any debts thanks to
father paying for
my tuition and really started above
where a lot of my peers were
but lived always paycheck to paycheck
moved out on my own with no cushion or
savings
and basically spent most of my 20s doing
that
and um was able to actually reverse and
learn to budget and save up a good chunk
of money in
my mid to late 20s about three years ago
but um ended up due to
some unforeseen circumstances with a bad
um apartment where the landlord wasn't
able to
provide a healthy living environment um
made me use a chunk of that to move and
living on my own i just
spent all my feelings away just because
i
ended up going through like a depression
of some sort um
i released the money i had saved up and
it ran out before i knew it and
fell back into that paycheck to paycheck
cycle
since then i've worked with therapists
and i feel like my mental health has
improved but it wasn't until a year ago
when the pandemic
fit that i feel it was the worst and
best thing that could have happened to
me
um yes uh worst case scenario happened
with
uh work-life balance lines has blurred
but um you know it really got me to
focus on
my finances um i got furloughed
temporarily for three months starting in
april
so i was able to save a lot of my
unemployment
up until then and coming back from work
uh in july i was really able to
make a decision to move out of new york
city alexandra
alexandra alexander we only got about
two minutes before we got a commercial
break and your question is how can i
feel more secure about money
so do you have any debt i know you were
debt-free coming out of college have you
acquired debt are you still debt-free
uh i have a 3k in
debt um just from a zero percent credit
card
that i bought a macbook computer in all
right so you guys could pay off
okay tomorrow i have 24 000
in savings okay so here's the deal um
alexandra alexander here's what you do
you got 24 000 in savings or you're back
working correct
yes and i've increased my job since my
my income increased 50 percent great so
here's the deal
since november the way you feel more
secure about money
is to understand who is in control of
your
money and you are in control of your
money once before
you have saved up a lot of money you
went through a tough season of life and
you spent all of that savings
but now you're on your way back you got
24 000 savings
you have figured out how to do this a
couple times so you've got to work
our ramsey solutions baby steps and so
take 24 000
you need to cut a check tonight you need
to pay it as soon as this phone call is
over
and so now you're going to be down to 21
000. you pay off that credit card and
cancel the credit card you don't need it
so now all of a sudden you have no debt
and then you are working on
that's baby step one uh excuse me the
snap
that snowball pay off the one debt now
we're gonna work on baby step two
excuse me baby step uh uh three which is
uh your
three to six months expenses so what is
that amount what of your salary right
now what is three to six times okay
so now now you're now you're almost done
with baby step three if you want to go
to six months
i would why not go ahead and really save
you know get really secure
you want more security have a bigger
emergency fund we recommend three to six
months so you're ready so that's how you
feel more secure you follow the plan
and uh goodness gracious i'm so excited
i've i got the baby steps all mixed up i
know what they are
john but she's there right there she's a
baby step three now she can
say fifteen percent that's baby step
four and for income and now she's
she's a young lady she's gonna be uh a
network millionaire if she just keeps on
saving
folks security comes with a plan keep
security
with discipline keep doing the right
goal
just do the right thing and security
comes your way all right
don't move more of your calls coming up
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by dr john deloney as we
take your calls about your life
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to david
in cincinnati ohio david how can we help
hey gentlemen how you doing today we are
loving life what's going on
that's awesome i have a question for you
i'm i'm
kind of in the process of need your
guidance on
going about um probably
how do i search for a new career is
there suggestions that you would have
that
uh maybe like uh i don't know if there's
like an attitude test or things of that
nature that would just give me some
ideas of different career options about
my job to get into
sure uh let's start with what you've
always wondered about because a guy who
calls up and says hey i'm thinking about
switching
at some point in your life you had some
other ideas
and wondered about some things that you
might do when you grow up
maybe it was when you're nine maybe when
you're 19 maybe it was nine months ago
or nine minutes ago
let's start there because i i'll i'll
walk you through this but i want to know
what you've wondered about
the only thing that i've ever my only
passion i've ever had has been law
enforcement and i'm
probably a little bit too old to get
into that how old are you now
i'm 45 nope you're not too old yeah
excuse one god yeah so why law
enforcement tell me why
i'll tell them guys i'll blow your
theory on the water i've applied for fhp
twice i've been denied both times i've
applied for the city of orlando i've
been denied
i've applied for the city of cincinnati
have been denied so guys come on
i can only take so much of that before
you really feel like it's never going to
happen you know
okay hold on hold on i get that that's
one of those things i get it you're just
stuff
you know i get it and i understand
you're a human being
i know you are i was about to say you're
discouraged but you're also wrong
and and i don't want to beat up on you
too much because you're already
discouraged but let me tell you
something
uh 45 is not too old there's no manual
there's no unwritten rule
throughout the united states where these
local law enforcement officers or even
federal law enforcement are saying well
45 is too old and and so but let me tell
you this if you feel like you're too old
you'll act like it's not an option and
you won't stay with this this is a tough
field to get into
uh you're talking to a guy who got into
broadcasting
uh starting at the age of 33. so i'm not
going to allow you to keep telling
yourself this but let me i want you to
answer the question that i asked you i'm
going somewhere with this
why sure do you want to be a law
enforcement officer
the biggest reason is i like the
diversity i like to get some
opportunities
the i like to
uh i like that it's
it's not you can yeah you can stop on
the side of the road and help somebody
but
there's also a risk there so i like i
like the fact that
you have the off you have the authority
to stop and say hey how can i help you
is everything okay
along with of course enforcing law and
when there's things that happen you're
the one that responds to it
and it's not a question of oh you know
so it's not
just well yeah you could be a good
samaritan but it's just it's just having
the ability
because it's expected because it's your
job and so it's not like oh
well i grew up here and and the streets
were like this and now the crime's bad
and i'm gonna go out here and be the
superman and say but i'm not trying to
do that
i just there's always something that
appealed to me and i i like
uh investigation um there's things about
that that really appeals to me so it was
always something that's been my passion
yeah of course you know yes why did i
pursue it years ago well i tried
and then quite frankly some of the
people that i talked to that weren't
upset but it probably wasn't a good idea
to do
when i had my children it made sense and
now that my children are gone i tried it
again
good and you know here's what i want you
to hear i wanted you to list out all the
reasons why this kind of work
fires your soul up and you did a great
job listing it out
so what you've got to then say is is
law enforcement the only way to do that
kind of work so i'm going to challenge
you here
to realize that it's not just law
enforcement to do that kind of work
what are other ways to protect people
what are other ways to serve people
there are functions and roles that a law
enforcement officer does during the day
that exist in other places
so i want you to expand your mind but i
also want you to understand that you
getting into
a law enforcement job is all about why i
wrote the book the proximity principle
which says in order to do what you want
to do david you got to be around people
that are doing it in places where it is
happening what does that mean
practically that means
you have got to spend time with police
officers or federal
officers you've got to get to know them
and they get to know you
and then all of a sudden you're not just
a nameless faceless person
who is applying for a job you are
somebody who has come highly recommended
hey let me tell you about my friend
david
this guy's got the chops he's got the
passion for it uh
and they start making connections for
you they're ultimately not going to get
you hired
but they are going to put you in a
position where you're not just somebody
competing at somebody else so all of a
sudden the 45 year old
has a chance to beat out the 35 year old
because of the relationships john
and i'm telling you that's how you get
in hard to get in fields that are so
very competitive you got to have that
edge that relationship now i've talked
to callers on the show and i want to
i want to call this out who have said
you don't really it's hard to get that
recommendation
kind of officially and i understand that
so don't go official
you still have relationships and you can
meet people so this is a situation where
you can't get discouraged you've got to
get determined and it sounds
cliche but that's really the case he's
not too old
no and and man
when you when you call somebody and this
is something man
it's just become a a a challenge for me
to process personally with my family
with what's going on in the country
when you call two people one of which
has
i come from a law enforcement background
i've spent my entire career working with
law enforcement
both both on the payroll and
and in my communities and a guy who
does has a nationally syndicated show
helping people get with their jobs
and your response to their feedback is
instant anger
instant discouragement
you've got to be reflective enough to
say
am i applying for these jobs and i'm not
getting them for another reason or am i
going to create a reason why
and it's because i'm too old right i'm
just gonna i'm gonna come up with the
thing that i think the thing
the answer is right and so what i want
somebody who
is is is inventing answers or
getting discouraged or getting rejected
i know it's frustrating i know it's hard
you got to listen to the truth when
people tell you the truth hey it's not
because you're too old
what else is what else is holding you
back right what else is leaning on you
ken what do you tell folks who are
struggling with rejection after
rejection after rejection when they're
searching for a job searching for a job
what what what advice do you give well
so what we do is we retreat to clarity
okay
so let's get back to clarity on who i am
so do i have the talent to be a law
enforcement officer that's a hard
thing right well but hold on but but you
do a self-assessment then you get other
people in your life who are truth
tellers who know you well but will tell
you the truth right
not the american idol mom who tells
their daughter or son that they can sing
and they can't sing yeah so we go back
and wait a second do i have all of the
required skills and talent that this job
requires that's number one can i pass
the if i get into the academy can i pass
can i do it you got to do that so then
we move to passion do i love this work
right
how much do i want to do that's why i
asked him what's your why why do you
want to do this work
let's re-clarify why
because then that gets the heart feeling
good again right so we're discouraged
we're down because we got passed over
that's very personal yeah it is
so we got to snap back yeah one way to
do that do i have the chops to do this
if the answer is yes
check that box if do i love this work am
i passionate about it
if the answer is it makes your heart
beat thinking about doing that work oh
check that box already and now does that
work produce results
that really really fire your soul like
you
want to do this for the community i want
to protect them i want to serve them
right
i want to put a different brand on law
enforcement i want to be this guy
now we go check check check so now we're
clear again
yes i really want this are you going to
weigh back i know why and that gives me
the juice to step back in and face
rejection again because here's the deal
none of us john like to be rejected no
and especially about something
like david man i want to do this for a
long time yep and then my kids got in
the way
and i stepped out and i'm stepping back
in he's wanted to do this for a long
time and he's really down because it
hasn't happened here's the deal you
gotta double down
by the way kelly i meant to give david a
copy of my book the proximity principle
dave you gotta read this and do it
uh because the reality is is that john
i'm telling you when the normal resume
process
isn't turning something for you will you
at least try my process i know right
because it works and david i want you to
go find a law enforcement friend of
yours yes
and let them know i've applied to all
these places i'm i'm missing
some feedback what should i be looking
for a lot of times people don't get
feedback
yeah all right hey i want to thank our
producer james childs i want to thank
our associate producer kelly daniel i
don't want to thank my colleague
john delaney doctor jonathan just
regular john's good
america thank you for listening this is
your show this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
coming to you live from the headquarters
of ramsey solutions and broadcasting
from the dollar car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
life i'm ken coleman and i'm joined by
my colleague
dr john dolone we are ramsay
personalities we both host
shows as a part of the ramsey network he
hosts the dr john delony show where
he'll talk with you
one caller at a time about your
relationships your mental
and emotional health parenting's
involved in that all kinds of stuff
toxicity at work hello you'll deal with
some of that i mean it's just
all over the board and i on the ken
coleman show we'll talk with you about
figuring out what you were created to do
in your work
uh increasing your income
moving up the ladder for more impact
that's what we talk about
and we also talk about money as a result
of those conversations and
of course our role here on the ramsey
show so
what is your question how can we help
you triple eight eight two five five two
two five
is the number triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
atlanta georgia where david joins us
david
how can we help uh yes i was calling i
need to get some uh
term insurance and i was trying to
figure out how much to get
okay tell us your situation how old are
you tell us about your family
situation i'm 53 and married
i have two kids that are in college okay
so
uh what do they are they uh
what what's their plan are they almost
out of college how young are they what
are they planning to do
i've got one that's a junior in college
and one that's a freshman in college
okay uh so she'll be she'll be
graduating like after next year so
okay and what is your income and your
wife's income if she is working outside
the home
uh my income is one around 160 and hers
is about 66.
okay so call it 220ish that's safe
right right yeah um my take on that is
it you know if if and let me ask you
this too before i say this what is your
investment situation you have any debt
let's
fill out the rest of the financial
picture i
have i have no dad i have a uh i had i
do have a mortgage on the house
uh for 314 000 um
but the house is probably worth like
650. oh wow
fantastic yeah crushing it okay so
in retirement i've got um probably not
i'm sorry not 900
560 000. okay so at this point you are
not because of your investment situation
you're not you know self-insured uh
and so what you what i would recommend
dave and recommend too is ten
times uh your income so you know you
could do that just on you
if you wanted to or your wife but
because term insurance with xander
insurance is so affordable
uh to me i would do the two million two
and a half million if you want to do
that i'd run rates on it on just ten
times your
your um your your salary as well and uh
i also think because of your
financial situation i'd look at what it
would take to pay off a house
plus take care of your wife and the two
girls or
and again you're not having to take care
of the girls you know one of them
obviously is is a junior you want a
freshman
but what would you want you know your
life insurance policy to do
if you went much earlier than expected
and i think that helps you
frame up that 10x number but i think
for you anywhere between one and a half
to two and a half i think is the right
amount two and a half million
uh one and a half two and a half million
and you could also look at
uh potentially a separate policy if you
wanted to just run the numbers with one
of our
uh with xander insurance uh and you know
paying off the house as well
okay and and would you suggest the
15-year or the year
i'm 53 so i don't i didn't know if i
needed to do a 20 or
15. uh i think 15 because that gets you
to 68 but no no no do 20. because of the
the
you're healthy right now are you healthy
pretty healthy guy yeah i'm pretty
healthy
yeah so here's what's great every guy i
know
would answer i'm pretty healthy so i
don't know if dave would ever get this
detail but you and i will so let's do
this
so i did this two years ago uh david
okay i re-upped okay and because i was
in way better shape than i had been
before and i actually for the week of
the test
i went like super clean yeah dropped an
additional four pounds and the
cholesterol in the blood was
top rate i got the best rate possible so
david if you're five to ten
pounds from being you know some real
savings i'd do the 20 years
some real savings yeah awesome do 20
because that gets you to 73 that's
enough
yeah the the longer you go um the longer
the longer you wait to buy this policy
the more expensive it's going to get
right yeah so do it now
all right what do you think you you you
know knocking out the cheeseburgers for
the next 10 15
days before they get out there to the
house well i think the catches they
they kind of get you on that because
they say have you lost weight within the
last
you know certain amount of time so they
kind of um
there's kind of a catch there but um you
know i'll try to left cheeseburger
trust me you need the good whatever the
good cholesterol is and you got to get
rid of the bad cholesterol i'm telling
you
david you can do this man and then
here's the other thing this is all
rounding out in time for the summer
bathing suit season so we are saving
money we're looking better in our
swimsuit the wife is excited there's a
trifecta of goodness here dave david you
made one phone call and
we made every part of your life better
yeah we gave way more than you expected
which is what we do here on the ramsay
show
we'll give you a full holistic advice
we'll give you the whole nine yards
call xander they're they're her new
zander insurance trust my with my two
i'm with as well right that's who i
trust
that's who dave recommends but more
importantly they're great that's who i
use
to take care of my family in the event
that i pass away they're great and on
this show i've said it multiple times
i'm going to keep saying it
again one of if i look back and i think
through
the crisis stuff i've been involved with
those usually two in the morning
three in the morning there's very few
people the neighborhoods are asleep and
i roll into a house with my you know
with one or two partners
there's police officers there there's
ems there
there is few things on earth more
harrowing
yeah than sitting with somebody who's
just lost a spouse and they look you in
the eyes and they say
i don't know what to do next yeah
because they're gonna have to go to work
on monday
because they don't have any life
insurance they don't know if there's a
will they don't know they don't know
what comes next they just know that
we don't have enough money in savings to
cover the electric bill next time that's
right
and so don't do that get life insurance
yes
get a will take care of your family
something happens to me the house is
paid off
and stacey and the kids are set i'm in
that weird moment where
you're more valuable dead than you are
alive yeah by a margin yeah i know
that's how that works
by a margin man yeah the xander folks
took care of us so you know what we need
is we need like for these people these
large insurance policies we need some
sort of uh we need to invent the old
remember the old days in the
uh kelly kelly daniels in a history buff
like me you
had the tasters for people would taste
back in the day you took out a king with
a glass of wine oh
yeah do you know what i mean like that
that was the real deal yeah and so we
need that you know you start getting
you and i need some sort of instrument
to check the toxicity of our
beverages my wife loves me is all she
does she does
she does hey uh it's tax time john hey
i'm done
you're done i did it did you use smart
tax smart tax i did it at my kitchen
table
it was awesome all right well listen uh
your taxes don't have to be that
complicated
text the word tax to 33789 to learn more
on our smart tax program text the word
tax
to three three seven eight nine and use
ramsey smart tax it's a game changer
what i used and it was awesome it works
hey don't move
more of the ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life same time
financial christian healthcare
ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget-friendly option and the original
health cost sharing ministry for
christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back america you're listening to
the ramsey show i'm ken coleman joined
by my colleague dr john dolone the phone
number to jump in on the conversation is
triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple a
eight two five five two two five let's
go to dayton ohio
where ronda joins us rhonda how can we
help
hi guys um really nice to meet you both
it's good to talk to you
i am looking for some advice on what to
do
as far as relationship goes with money
we've been married for 36 years
and we don't do well together
in any way shape or form we have gone to
several different streams where we just
did our own thing
and then i tried to step back and said
okay you handle it all
and that got kind of scary and
he didn't talk to me he doesn't tell me
anything and i looked up a little
bankruptcy
because he wasn't paying the house
payment and i didn't know
um now the tables have turned
and i make more money than he's making
and we're still not talking and i
we have been to counseling i don't know
what to do anymore
and we're getting too old to continue
this honestly
because i'm going to retire one day and
i'm going to be debt-free
but how can i be debt-free if we're not
debt-free
now when you say you're not talking uh
you mean not talking at all or not
talking about money
i'm not talking about anything okay you
talk about everything else
um mostly mostly yeah we do actually
how would you describe your relationship
let's take money off the table
how would you describe your relationship
on a scale of one to ten one being
non-existent
and ten you're you're you're in puppy
love
no we don't have any puppies right now
but yeah right actually we're probably a
seven
a seven a seven
because what i hear in your voice is
exhaustion yeah borderline resentment
and you if i had to guess
tell me i'm wrong okay if i had to guess
you're experiencing what
millions of women have experienced over
the last 15 25 years
which is once they begin to gain that
economic independence they don't got to
put up with this crap anymore
and at the same time
so it's not that i'm not well the reason
i'm not there is because i love my
husband and i'm not
trying to get anywhere and and but you
are right i am pushing back
yeah you're absolutely right and i know
that does he have i know
rhonda does he have separate bank
accounts as did i understand that am i
picking that up
oh well yeah there's another nightmare
we
we finally put our accounts together and
we were supposed to be talking about it
and doing things right and
we ended up filing bankruptcy and and
then he
took his money out of the account and so
for the last several years
we actually finished a bankruptcy i know
like some of the only people on the
planet that actually finished one
and we did um
he he turned around and took took his
money out doing the bankruptcy and said
i'm going to pay the bankruptcy payment
and then we'll use yours for this but i
don't want the bankruptcy payment to get
messed up
and so he took his money out and now the
bank's rope has been over for
four or five years and the money's still
all together but the only money in there
is mine
yeah so and i looked up and take the
money out and do it i'm like what are
you doing so i go back to him i said
dear what is this bill
oh well that was this well all that was
this was like okay what's going on with
your money where's your money well you
know i don't make that much anymore so
it's i'm tired
yeah i'm telling you and i'm trying not
to do
well you don't try not to be tired
because that's gonna
it's just gonna result in you taking
those feelings
and that's that's that is what
resentment is right when you just smash
and
crush and hide those feelings they just
smolder and burn from inside out
right and that you can't come back from
resentment it's so hard to return from
that
it sounds like you're married to
somebody who um
has all kinds of struggles is that fair
is he struggling with all kinds of
things over the course of your 36 years
yeah that's true and
i i really am in my heart i've talked to
i can't count the number of people i've
talked to over the years
this is rare you're talking your
marriage is a seven
i'm assuming your intimate life is
awesome you are you laugh together you
play you share meals you share chores
and this much heat comes from
the money part that's so so rare
well i love my husband does he love you
he knows it
absolutely but not enough to be honest
and open in a person of integrity and
character when it comes to
money not knowing that his wife is so
exhausted that she's falling apart under
underneath this this burden
right because if you tell me somebody
loves me then they don't
the person that's walking alongside life
with him doesn't feel like this
does he know that you are this exhausted
yeah and what's his response
uh we'll talk about it later nope
they're not going to disagree with
the i'm going to disagree well i'ma tell
you this if you walked in
and i was coaching you two in my living
room
i would tell your marriage is at a two
not a seven yeah it's not even close to
a seven
and and i'm going to tell you something
else um
i don't think this is a does he
no i think you love him i think you love
a
i think you love a fantasy i think you
love a myth
but here's the thing john i'm going to
say this i love saying things and
letting you clinically explain what i'm
saying
it's like i'm going to drop a fact you
give her the formula this is not about
how much does he love how much he loves
you no
this is he's broken i i think he does
love you but this isn't about he needs
to love her better
i think this this guy is really really
broken and he's trying to
just keep his head above water he's
trying to fill a hole or maybe several
holes
and his money behavior and everything
else john is a derivative of that
that's what i think yeah i i i don't
like to characterize people as broken
right but i'm sorry you're he's hurting
can i say that absolutely okay
um and
he's hurting big time yeah this is
somebody who's been struggling with
who am i my role power suddenly
his wife over time starts making more
money starts getting more of a voice
and at some point and this this again
this isn't just this family this
is it this is a pandemic of men
struggling over the last 25 35 45 years
of
being told you are the cause of these
problems
not understanding what my role is not
understanding what hard work looks like
plus feeling my feelings plus being able
to sit down i don't have the tools in my
toolkit to have hard conversations
i'm gonna do it tomorrow i'm gonna do it
tomorrow i'm gonna do it tomorrow and
the the women in our lives the kids in
their lives
are the casualties here and the chief
casualty is just
the men right so here's the thing um
you got to come to the table with your
husband at the end of the day you're
going to have to make peace
with a guy that you're married to you
say you love him you say it is what it
is
you're gonna have to go one more shot
and you're gonna have to say
this has to be different and then you're
gonna have to have what they call in the
clinical world they call your or what
moment
are you gonna leave because if you're
not then you gotta make peace with it
and then get on about your life if you
are going to leave
you got to have that hard conversation
preferably with a professional
in the room because you don't want to be
making threats and and threaten to walk
away
but you're at a place now where you've
got to make the decision if the person
in your life won't change you can only
control you
right and you're going to have to either
say this is a guy married this is what
it is what it is
we're going to ride this out or you're
going to have to make some other life
decisions
right but that's where that sounds like
where you're at this is 36 years it's
almost four decades
right yeah i oh man this is
really tough yep and i want to encourage
every
single husband listening to this yeah
check in with your wives check in with
the people you are married to
tonight and and here's the deal get
healthy
i do believe this man loves her but this
isn't you and i grabbing him by the
collar and going love your wife no no
this is he's got some hurt and some pain
and he's trying to save it and she's
in a really tough situation but do not
quit i wanna hug this guy i wanna hug
this guy
i do too do not quit rhonda don't
quit please don't quit
we're not going to quit on you we got
more of the ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr
john dalone you need to find out for
yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run
every month you'll save even more use
the promo code ramsay to get the best
deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from jenny in florida
she says i work for a large retail
company who was able
to stay afloat during the pandemic
because we were considered an essential
business i was very fortunate to keep my
job which i love
however our company just announced to us
that there would be no merit increases
this year not even a cost of living
raise
but we are going to receive our bonuses
for me
it's probably about two thousand dollars
i really love my job
but is this a red flag to start looking
elsewhere
what no what are you doing jenny let me
re-read your question back to you you
start by saying
i love my job but our company said no
merit increases this year which by the
way
uh the standard increase about three
percent
yeah yeah uh in american business let's
go back let's go back before that
my large company survived the pandemic
yeah
hey hello we survived many did not no
and their jobs did not so we survived
yeah and i love it continue and
while they're not going to give a merit
increase or a cost of living raise
they are going to give out bonuses
ken you and i don't agree on a lot and
for both of us to be like
what are you saying dude
yeah jenny i appreciate the question no
that's not a red flag you ought to be
running in the neighborhood around the
backyard
in in the living room singing in the
shower i'm so grateful that i get a
bonus this year while many people are
unemployed so no this is not a red flag
i get a bonus
doing a job i love not only is this not
a red flag john
this actually speaks to the viability of
this company
yes that they were able to give out
bonuses they managed their books
well enough during the pandemic to
actually be in a position to give out
bonuses
right and it wouldn't surprise me i've
got zero data this i'm
way into your territory here that we're
gonna see this more and more moving
forward
because if a pandemic can come out of
nowhere
and wipe us out right and our most
expensive thing is ongoing ever
increasing payroll
it makes sense to me that we're going to
hand you a big pile of cash at the end
of every year based on how this goes but
we're not going to strap ourselves with
this ever increasing payroll yeah right
because then we only
we have to continue to increase our
costs et cetera et cetera
man if you love your job and your jobs i
mean you're
working for a company that can navigate
this and still write your bonus checks
yep some result time yeah now we don't
have time for co-host counseling live on
the air right but you just told
america that we don't agree on much
that's not true i want to talk to you
about that why did you say that we agree
on
a lot we agree on a lot of things do we
i'm just kidding i think we do a lot but
you said it not me politics and
economics we love to bicker back and
forth right
yeah we have different views but it's
not like we're you know oh i didn't yeah
i didn't mean that as well
be careful what you say people think
that we're fighting during the
commercials
no no no i'm just having fun with you
all right
eight triple eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight
eight two five did you like my co-host
counseling i thought that was kind of a
funny line you just you just went right
over we could skip the uh i didn't get
what you're saying
i didn't know where you're headed with
it no i like that you know we could
counsel each other right here on the air
we should do that you want to talk about
some political topics right now no
no by the way before we get to the
fights you want some advice
don't talk politics with anybody no
especially
maybe not even your wife or your kids i
just think it's gotten to the point
where it's like
ludicrous what what is the point like
the dog i think that one of my doodles
would argue with me at this point if i
just said something in the house
look at me like you're wrong you're
wrong so much vitriol
too there used to be a day where you
could sit around
you know a martini or a beer with some
people and just talk about all different
points of view and everybody like
that's interesting cool yeah
not anymore man no i'm going to learn to
dump your grill over and
yeah me and my me and my kids were
taking our ball we're going home
yeah yeah so don't catch a wine glass in
the temple
don't talk about it at all not good
anyway triple eight eight two five five
two two five people that's some good
life advice there triple eight eight two
five
five two two five james is joining us in
denver colorado james how can we help
hey how are you guys doing today well
we're having a blast how can we help
um so i'll try to keep it short but i've
got a
couple of attributes to this question so
about a year ago i uh gave a personal
loan to my girlfriend of about three
thousand dollars
of that she has paid back 1500 so she
still has
1500 left on the agreement
since that time three things have
happened number one
because of the pandemic she had to take
a different job making about
half the amount of money she was making
number two
we both started financial peace and we
are both on baby step
two and number three we recently got
engaged
we're getting married in about six
months
given all that's going on right now i
kind of feel like
it would be best to just
forgive the rest of the loan it doesn't
feel right to me to keep it
but i'm also afraid because our
relationship has always been a
50 50 partnership that it's going to
come off
like i'm trying to lord over her
or be better than her um
and i also have all the debts don't pay
off so
i was wondering uh should i just go
ahead and try to tell her not to
pay it back and how do i approach that
without seeming weird
okay you sound weird you do sound weird
because
i would never utter the phrase my fiance
owes me money
in a billion years that sentence can't
come out of
of my mouth no i don't know how it comes
out of your mouth i don't think this is
a her issue this is a usu this is a wee
issue john my goodness i don't even know
where to start well
yeah there's a lot here so
if you are not able to have a
conversation that says
hey i did something stupid we didn't
know
we didn't know about um the we didn't
have the wisdom
about loaning money to people that were
in
uh romantic relationships with or
friendships or family right
give it away or say no
dude we're not we're done with this debt
repayment situation
if that becomes a lording over a power
struggle
man you guys got to get to a premarital
counselor
tomorrow right you are not in a position
to get married because dude the
conversations y'all be having about
kids and work and where we're gonna live
and family and i'm sick i need some
support
they get harder and harder and harder
this is a
simple one absolutely
when is the wedding day uh
about six months six months from now
well
six months from now you walk down the
aisle she doesn't owe you any more money
i guess i mean i guess i guess if she
breaks up with you today or you break it
with her then we can talk about that but
if you're getting married it becomes our
money it's hourly i mean i married
stacey she had a masters in broadcast
journalism i
married her student loans
yeah yeah so so it wasn't like it wasn't
like oh i'm paying
every time i wrote a check and they go
well i'm paying your master's degree
that's right no you're in it together so
james you you said you're you're both 50
50. is that a hard
who is this more challenging for
i i feel like it would be more
challenging for her
um it because that has always been a
great
sense of pride for her right that she is
you know her own person she's making a
way in the world you know i i feel like
it's something that comes from
the way she was raised her family
dynamics certainly something that i
personally would would push back against
and i
agree with everything that you're saying
oh well then i think you just have to
have a straight up conversation here to
say hey
you are who you are you're you're an
independent woman you're all these
wonderful things
i loaned you some money big deal it's
going to be our money
don't even think of it that way you're
going to help pay this whole thing off
anyway yeah
and this whole 50 50 talk brother it's
0.50.50
and you're about to become one you're
gonna have to get with somebody and work
on that before you all
attach yourselves to each other forever
man and don't
be very careful about psychoanalyzing
your fiance
you only get with the premarital
counselor today yes absolutely true
all right we're not done yet folks
don't move more of your calls coming up
next this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman in studio with my colleague dr
john deloney
who's uh deciding now to join us
everything okay over there
words with friends on the phone before
we come back from commercial break
gotta tap you on the shoulder and say
hey you know for me he's trying to
solve some things i want to point out
that we did not have a plate of barbecue
we
we threw that out there we thought maybe
it would magically appear earlier in the
show
did not happen gotta have a plan
evidently bobby the engineer
is falling down on the job back there in
the control room the guy is a
world-class cook
um can absolutely grill smoke
i mean he's he needs his own restaurant
he does
he is his own restaurant he is his own
restaurant bobby i was just saying you
were you were doing engineer stuff
earlier
it would be great during the show next
time delaney and i co-host they have a
big giant platter of all things
bobby barbecue some sausage some brisket
some chicken some pork some beef and all
the sides
or as we say in the south fixins that's
f-i-x-i-n-s for people who aren't from
the south that's an actual word
all the fixins do you say that in texas
no what do you say
beans and cornbread salad now fixins
fixin's includes anything anything
that's on the table that's not an entree
is a
fixing and there's zero percent chance
bobby's gonna share
not true that's wrong hey you know what
he talks to you that way bring it in
here we'll put it on this side
and i'll just do the heisman and i'll
just eat while he's answering
relationship calls and i'll
wipe the mouth and we'll get into the
other stuff all right we're having fun
here
bobby really is a world-class cook and i
really would like to have some barbecue
during the show and we'll just do it
when dave's not here
yeah he doesn't care uh triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
i'm really getting hungry i really am no
you're you started a whole thing
inside my heart and mind here man
exactly triple eight eight two five five
two two five back to the phones we go
savannah georgia uh is where we're gonna
go oh you know what i'll get to this a
second let's go to uh kevin
uh in savannah georgia kevin how can we
guys i appreciate you taking the call
you bet um yeah yeah so to give you some
context me my wife got married about six
months ago
uh we've been doing super good we paid
off um over twenty three thousand
dollars and and college debt
thank you thank you we have about 1700
left
now my question is uh so she recently
got a
offer actually earlier today uh for a
different position in pennsylvania
and right now we're kind of deciding
whether to stay in savannah
or where we make about 80k groves or
go to pennsylvania where we'll be making
about 90k so about 10 grand more
um that's about the difference for the
two positions i work remotely so i can
work
either in savannah or pennsylvania and
most and to give you a little more
context most of our families in the
northeast
and pennsylvania and new york but we
have been here for six months we're
plugged into our church we've been doing
very very great going to life groups and
all that so
my question is should we just focus
mostly on the money making
a little bit more money so we can uh you
know start putting
um you know retirement savings and start
investing in our future
or should we just stay here knowing the
expenses are a little bit less then
kind of doing that interesting so john i
get these calls a lot on the game
show here man so well kevin gets to
answer this i can
i could say what i think but that's not
what this is about right this is about
us guiding them kevin there's two of you
in this marriage
i want to know what you and your wife
give me the two separate votes
your vote first her vote as it stands
right now which way you lean it
so great question so i mean olivia her
name uh
we actually don't know we we love
georgia we've been here for six months
like i said
we love the south we went to school um i
live in kentucky and in virginia she
lives in
in virginia and virginia and south
carolina so we love the south we think
we want to stay here and raise our kids
we haven't done yet but in the future
but we're super tied down we're not too
sure we've been praying about i've been
fasting about it this week
um i just we just don't know we're not
really siding
anywhere well i think you just gave us a
clue i think in that answer you just
kind of indicated you guys really love
the south and you have
at some point uh maybe through the the
short six months of your marriage you
guys have
uh kind of imagined a life in the south
am i right
uh-huh okay so here's the deal uh in
this situation
i think you guys i love that you're
praying about it you guys are talking
about it i think you guys could do the
old-fashioned
pros and cons list i love a pencil got
one right here i love a piece of paper
got some right here i draw a line
pros and cons for each of the moves pros
for staying
cons for staying i don't think there's
any cons other than the fact that you
say well i'm going to get it
my wife's going to get a ten thousand
dollar bump but you said there's a cost
of living
so i would actually run those numbers
john i'd run the cost and
cost a living increase plus taxes in the
state of pennsylvania
and i would compare it to your current
income plus your taxes cost of living in
savannah
that's a pretty easy side-by-side
comparison you can get pretty close
there
and i think i would do that for your
brain for your logic because ultimately
after the brain gets engaged john i
think it comes down to the heart that's
right
and kevin i know how tempting it is when
you guys have a plan
and the plan probably went something
like hey we're going to live here for a
few years then we're going to end up
moving back northeast with all the
family
and then suddenly you like it right and
yeah you get plugged in there and moving
back home maybe isn't quite what it
might have been cracked up to be and we
had a plan but
man we really like it here well we kind
of beat you to it so i have the pros and
cons list here
that a boy yeah in a very kind of macro
sense
so the difference is about 5k give or
take so we won't be making
you know crazy tons more um but we are
going to be closer slightly to our
family so our kind of thinking
is um that she has so the the hospital
here that she's working at
it's a little bit larger and the one in
pennsylvania is a little bit smaller so
she'll have
kind of growth potential a little better
over there um
so that's kind of the side on that and
so he might be making more
maybe two years on the line how old are
you kevin
i'm 24 and she's 24 as well okay so i'm
going to give you a magic gift you ready
doesn't matter what you do you can't
lose so true
you you stay for two more years she's a
hospital employee she's clearly good
she's gonna have another opportunity you
all moved to pennsylvania and realized
what did we do
this was disaster parents are annoying
now that we're married
they're hassling us come back to georgia
come back to nashville come back to
huntsville alabama there'll be plenty
opportunities yep so whatever you do
look at it in 24 month chunks 36 month
chunks you're not tied into anything
this isn't the end of time for y'all
don't get this it's not a forever thing
here
okay trust your gut kevin i know you
called because you're like i'm gonna run
this by
john and ken and i'm hoping they're
gonna say that one of these is the clear
winner that's what he was hoping for
it's not our one it's not our call
because there's not a clear winner
that's right
and i think what you said is beautiful
i'm going to tell you that that's
beautiful because
because i think of some of the moves
stacey and i made early in our first
year we were in richmond virginia for
one year and then we took a great
opportunity to come to nashville well
you know what
you could look at and go god directed
our past and he did and you know but had
we stayed in richmond it would
have been great too you know that we
overthink these things
and i gotta tell you john i'm a fan of
getting your brain out of these
decisions you're free
i think it's the heart you're free i
think i don't listen kevin i'm having
some fun with you brother but this is
all positive
i don't believe you that there is not a
clear winner in your heart
it might be john yeah 52
you know 48 it might be one of those
deals
it might be really close but i don't
believe that given the just let's look
at it let's get our head out of this
deal which he's done the head stuff
the good head stuff john i don't know
what do you think i think he wants to
stay
i think i heard that too he loves the
south
and i think they're trying to talk
themselves into moving across the
country for five thousand i'm going to
add something else to it i don't think
they're trying to talk themselves into
it i think their family
is trying to talk them into it and it
gets back to this deal we don't want to
let down the people that we love the
most but we're going
it does make sense that anybody any
normal person would want to be near
their family until you know five
thousand more dollars and then you go
but that's not what my heart wants
that's right and my guess is she could
walk into the place
that she works right now and say hey i
have this opportunity and
i'll get a looser for 500 a month follow
your heart kevin that's right
i don't think there's anywhere close oh
i love that you can't lose brother you
can't lose
hey uh our scripture today got a little
out of order because i got excited about
the barbecue but hey we're still getting
it in john
scripture today philippians 2 3 do
nothing from rivalry or conceit but in
humility count others more significant
than yourselves today's quote one of my
mentors
former leader had the privilege of
working with this man john maxwell to
add value to others one must
first value others
that's good i tell you what not a lot of
words but a lot of depth one of the
great curses
of our time yeah we don't value each
other enough
no we don't place the right amount of
value on people hey i value you and you
too man
appreciate my colleague dr john delay i
want to thank our producer ben hill our
associate producer kelly daniel
and you america thank you because
we do this for you this is your show and
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you